bei mir ist jetzt katja suding die vize
chefin der fdp bundestagsfraktion und
der fdp bundestags partei und an sie
frau so liegen gleich die frage wer
hören schrille worte aus den usa was
denkt man als deutscher politiker wenn
man worte hört wie den totalen krieg
wollen oder stoppt die zählung von osram
familie natürlich zutiefst verstörend
und diejenigen die vorausgesagt haben
dass das land noch weiter gespalten wird
das trump an die der lage nicht
akzeptieren würde wissen es ja noch
nicht die haben offenbar recht behalten
und das ist natürlich für uns er hat
zutiefst verstörend und ich hätte es
auch nicht für möglich gehalten dass ein
sohn eines präsidentschaftskandidaten
solche worte benutzen wir natürlich mit
dem dritten reich mit göppels in
verbindung bringen was wünschen sie sich
denn egal wer jetzt präsident wird er
sieht sehr natur beiden aus aber was
muss sich denn ändern im verhältnis
deutschland und usa
wir müssen so realistisch sein als
europäer dass wir wissen dass es da
keine fundamentale kehrtwende geben wir
müssen einfach akzeptieren dass egal wer
gewinnt ob es trump ist oder beiden dass
die usa dass amerika nicht weiterhin
unseren so liberale weltordnung
garantieren wird das müssen wir schon
selbst machen wir brauchen also als
europäer mehr selbstbewusstsein dieser
hinsicht wir müssen das auch schaffen
mit einer stimme zu sprechen
da müssen wir sehr viel mehr
verantwortung übernehmen es wird
natürlich einen unterschiedlichen stil
geben je nachdem wer gewinnt ob es
klappt oder beiden sein wird aber im
fundamental gehe ich nicht davon aus
dass es da wirklich ein
ein wechsel in der außen und
sicherheitspolitik geben wird wenn wir
jetzt hier rechts aus dem fenster gucken
von von ihnen aus gesehen schauen wie
das kanzleramt was müsste sich dann aus
dem kanzleramt heraus ändern was muss
denn da anders gemacht werden damit hier
europa stärker aufgestellt kriegen so
wie sieht das fordern jetzt müssten
ernst genommen werden dass wir uns als
europäer anders aufstellen müssen dass
wir selbstbewusster sein müssen
und da gibt es ja schon seit einiger
zeit seit etwa drei jahren liegen ja die
vorschläge von emanuel mark raum
beispielsweise auf dem tisch für eine
neue europäische sicherheitsarchitektur
da gibt es aus berlin immer noch keine
antwort wir brauchen endlich eine eine
debatte und ein fortschritt so dass die
europäer da auch mehr selbstbewusstsein
zeigen können und ihre verantwortung
ihre rolle in der welt auch einnehmen
können wir das wird die usa egal wer
gewinnen wird nicht weiter sein
selbstbewusstsein nur in handelsfragen
oder auch in militärischen fragen das
gilt auch für militärische fragen das
gilt für fragen der der geheimdienst
zusammenarbeit wir haben uns ja als
deutsche sehr daran gewöhnt dass die
amerikaner sozusagen die drecksarbeit
für uns auch machen dass es jahrzehnte
lang hier in deutschland konsens gewesen
und es zeichnet sich auch schon vor der
tramp administration ab dass die
amerikaner das nicht weiter machen
werden und deswegen ist es längst
überfällig und es auch genug zeit hier
eigene konzepte und eigene stärken zu
entwickeln
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren